[Music]
breaking news this Sunday night another
day another shoot down the latest
mysterious object spotted in American
airspace brought down by the U.S
turkey's expanding humanitarian crisis
the heartache
and hardship she says nobody should have
to go through this earthquake survivors
left homeless now living in tents in
bone chilling conditions
real estate risks the potential pitfalls
when making pre-construction purchases
and a Canadian woman's emotional Journey
from Rock Bottom to mountaintops I
really did not think that life was worth
living her colossal comeback and climb
into history
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us the U.S military has shot down yet
another flying objects the fourth in
eight days Nora detected the latest one
in Canadian airspace yesterday before
losing track of it in Montana and then
early this morning what officials
believe is the same object was detected
again as it reached Michigan's Upper
Peninsula the object was flying at about
twenty thousand feet the U.S determined
it was a potential risk to civil
aviation and shot it down the debris is
believed to be on the Canadian side of
Lake Huron in a statement Canada's
defense minister says of the shoot down
we unequivocally support this action and
will continue to work with the U.S and
NORAD to protect North America Reports
say the object was shaped like an
octagon with strings hanging off it and
it didn't appear to be carrying anything
when asked if this involved
extraterrestrials NORAD Commander
General Glenn van hurk said he wouldn't
rule out anything just yesterday the the
U.S shot down a different flying object
over the Yukon crews are now on the
ground in Canada's Western Arctic
searching for debris prime minister
Justin Trudeau himself is on the way to
the Yukon our chief political
correspondent David Aiken joins us now
David that trip had been previously
planned but there were questions about
why the Canadian military itself didn't
take down the object well far the call
was made by Canada's prime minister the
safety of Canadians is our number one
priority and that's why I made the
decision to shoot down the object but
the shot was made by an American fighter
pilot yeah it sounds like it should be
easy it's not it's quite an intricate
process
and It's Complicated by the fact that
most of the Weaponry that's carried by
our Fighters uh is optimized for
fast-moving things Tom Lawson started
his military career as a fighter pilot
and eventually became Canada's top
General but he also served as the top
Canadian General at NORAD headquarters
in Colorado Springs I've seen a lot of
reaction from Canadians who are saying
why wasn't this a Canadian pilot do we
need to worry is this because we're not
capable of doing it on our own well
first of all I have to say that as a
Canadian boy I wish it had been a
Canadian pilot who shot it down I'm sure
the the Canadian pilots who are racing
up there over the Yukon were hoping they
would get there first too but beyond
that no this actually is significant and
symbolic of the uh strength of the NORAD
agreement so far military authorities
have not yet said what the balloon might
have been doing or where it came from
but it was the third balloon to have
been shot down in NORAD airspace in the
last two weeks and there's no question
the first one came from China that said
U.S authorities said the Yukon object
was smaller and did not resemble the one
known to have come from China prime
minister Justin Trudeau and U.S
President Joe Biden spoke Saturday about
next steps for NORAD we will continue to
do everything necessary to protect the
sovereignty of our Airs of our shared
North American airspace but also to do
everything necessary to keep our
citizens safe Trudeau will spend the
night Ian White Horse he'll meet with
indigenous leaders this evening he'll
meet with Yukon Premier Ranch Poli
Monday morning and he's promised he will
provide yukoners and all Canadians with
any new information that comes from the
analysis of the debris field Farah
certainly a lot of interest in that
thank you David it has been nearly a
week since the most devastating
earthquake in recent history the number
of lives lost grows every day 33 000
people have died in turkey and Syria and
there are fears less stories of rescues
and finding Signs of Life in freezing
temperatures are diminishing but today
this 11 year old girl and her father
were found they may be among the last to
be pulled from the rubble alive as this
week the mission will turn from Rescue
to recovery
tens of thousands of earthquake
survivors are now living in makeshift
tent cities it's the only option after
many buildings were destroyed or damaged
caring for so many people in the dead of
winter is no small task our Jackson
prosco visited one camp in the city of
valbestan where he found anger and
despair
[Applause]
cold in Elba stand a frigid minus 12 in
the shattered second epicenter of the
earthquake
no place to be homeless but tens of
thousands of survivors are they're left
to live in tents in large relief camps
run by the Turkish government
here Aid workers try to keep children
occupied a game of ball is a distraction
from the horrors they've witnessed
volunteers like Youssef have traveled
here from across the country a bowl of
hot soup can go a long way in these
temperatures what do you tell people to
keep them hopeful
we are not alone everyone is here we are
all Brothers
they are not alone these tents tell the
story of turkey's housing crisis there
are more than 5 000 people being housed
here and this is just one encampment in
one city
in these exceptional circumstances life
is exceptionally difficult each tent
houses six to eight people entire
families live in close quarters the thin
walls offer little protection against
the Turkish winter survivors describe
the heating stoves as more symbolic than
functional
everyone here is traumatized this woman
approached our interpreter to share the
horrors she had witnessed
she says nobody should have to go
through this she said it was freezing
cold in her tent at night still she was
grateful to have it she had nothing but
her clothes and a jar of jam she found
for her granddaughters
still Turkish officials are wary of
anything that would portray their
response as lacking
this man whose identity we've hidden was
speaking to us about the realities he
faced
when he was surrounded by government
relief workers who shouted insults
calling him an ungrateful traitor
we were soon advised to leave these are
just the first few days of what are sure
to be months in these tent cities for
now they are the best and only hope for
survivors
Jackson prosco Global News albistan
turkey
many have been pointing the finger of
blame on construction regulations not
being followed and turkey has vowed to
arrest the developers it says is
responsible for the collapse of
thousands of apartment blocks over 130
suspects have been identified and some
already contained including this man who
police say was on his way to Georgia
when he was stopped by police a special
earthquake crimes investigation Bureau
has been set up in each of the affected
cities
now getting Aid into the most affected
regions continues to be difficult and in
some areas outbreaks of violence are
adding to the challenge but as Redmond
Shannon reports on the other hand
political differences are being put
aside as both turkey and Syria are
getting help from unlikely places
patrols on the rubble-filled streets
after some foreign aid groups in Turkey
paused operations saying it's unsafe for
their workers amid reports of looting
and violence in some places
elsewhere in Turkey a friendly Embrace
that belies normally tense relations the
Greek foreign minister and his Turkish
counterpart observe Aid efforts together
this weekend also saw a border post
between turkey and another neighboring
foe Armenia opened for the first time in
35 years allowing Armenian Aid to get
through a small diplomatic thaw in
Damascus to the first European help
arrives into the Syrian Capital these
ambulances shipped from Italy it comes
after a Syria's government said it would
allow humanitarian Aid to cross battle
lines into rebel-controlled areas of the
country the earthquakes affected people
living in regions controlled by
opposition Fighters and the governing
regime of Bashar al-assad is has been
sanctioned by the West for years
although Aid was technically exempt we
welcome the easing of sanctions by the
United States World Health Organization
leaders visited government-controlled
Aleppo this weekend they hope to cross
into opposition areas soon
that with his Excellency president Assad
who indicated he was open to considering
additional cross-border access points
that could mean Aid can more easily get
to Rebel areas from Turkey too it would
need approval this coming week at the
United Nations from Assad's biggest
backer Russia in those Rebel areas there
has still been almost no outside help
you're a surgeon Mustafa al-yamani says
he has worked six straight days almost
Around the Clock Local Heroes
shouldering even more ways with no rest
on the horizon Redmond Shannon Global
News London
joining me now is Rahul Singh he is the
executive director of the humanitarian
Aid organization Global medic he has
teams in both Syria and turkey and he
joins me now from Toronto where the
coordination is happening Earl thanks
for speaking with us let's talk about
the difference between both countries
when it comes to Aid
yeah this is really A Tale of Two
tragedies that are unfolding at the same
time first you've got turkey 10 major
cities affected several million people
affected up to a million homeless the
entire world has responded 45 country
teams have come in to help racing
Against Time To Save folks and then
you've got Syria where you had 5 million
people flee the fighting come into
Northwestern Syria 90 of them needed Aid
before the earthquake and no one is
coming in to help them
and how how hard is it to get in there
for for your team
well you can imagine like just that
whole region is devastated right so
getting Aid just into that region in
Turkey is hard enough
now what we're doing is by trying to run
a supply chain across from Turkey into
Syria which we've always run it's much
harder because all those trucks all that
Personnel all the aid we would buy in
Turkey is now needed in Turkey so it's
really dried up and made it harder to
move Aid in so much so that we're
bringing Aid down from Bulgaria by truck
through turkey to get it into Syria so
you can imagine there used to be a tap
that flowed and now that's down to a
trickle at a time where needs inside
Syria have just immensely increased and
the World Health Organization is saying
there's going to be a secondary crisis
on top of this crisis so what's that
going to look like in the coming weeks
well look you always want to avoid the
secondary crisis right you can imagine
these poor folks in Syria they fled a
civil war they somehow managed to stay
alive from that Civil War then they're
in a building and it comes down on them
in an earthquake somehow they managed to
survive and come out I mean are they
going to die because they die of
starvation hungry and cold because the
world didn't get them Aid that's the
secondary Calamity that's going to occur
because not enough supplies and not
enough Aid are getting into Syria and
they simply don't have the
infrastructure or the help to keep
people alive
such a tragic situation we're all saying
we we really wish the best for your
Crews on the ground thanks so much for
joining us tonight
thank you
Canada's women's soccer team reluctantly
backs down
coming up why there will be no soccer
strike this season plus the risks of
pre-construction purchases the
unpredictable Market putting some in an
uncomfortable position
[Music]
the Canadian women's soccer team has
ended a short-lived strike after being
threatened with the legal action by
Canada Soccer
the team walked off training For an
upcoming tournament to protest pay and
equity and budget cuts to the women's
program in a statement the team says
Canada Soccer also considered collecting
millions in legal damages from the
players thus forcing them back to work
in a separate statement Canada Soccer
said though it respects the player's
right to organize they are not in a
legal strike position under Ontario
labor law
beginning today the public will be able
to say their final goodbye to former
Mississauga mayor Hazel mccallion
mccallion will lie in state at
Mississauga City Hall for two days ahead
of her State funeral on Tuesday but
would have been her 102nd birthday the
public is invited to pay their final
respects and offer their condolences to
the former mayor before she's laid to
rest mccallion who was one of Canada's
longest serving Mayors passed away one
week ago she served as mayor for 36
years from 1978 to 2014.
unseasonably warm weather is proving to
be the wet blanket spoiling some of the
fun during the second weekend of
ottawa's winterlude Festival higher
temperatures have been keeping the rodeo
Canal Skateway the world's largest
skating rink closed it actually hasn't
opened all season long the national
capital commission which maintains the
rink requires the ice to be 30
centimeters before allowing skaters to
lace up according to the organization it
usually takes about 10 to 14 consecutive
days of temperatures being minus 10 and
minus 20 to reach that thick last week
the Colder Weather did allow Crews to
flood portions of the canal and continue
the prep work and organizers are hopeful
the rink will open quote soon
[Music]
a head pre-sale pitfalls white
pre-construction purchases in this
market are exposing buyers to even more
risk
higher interest rates have had a
chilling effect on Canada's housing
market prices are down nearly 15 percent
since they peaked in early 2022 and
that's leaving buyers who purchased
pre-construction homes a couple years
ago in an uncomfortable position and
gaviola has more on what home buyers
should keep in mind in an unpredictable
Market
we purchased this house to be our
forever home basically we want to raise
our family there with their family
growing and both parents working from
home Yasser and Rabia craved more space
bidding wars made purchasing a suitable
home a challenge so they chose a
pre-construction home purchased from
mattamy homes in March 2022 at the peak
of the housing frenzy set for completion
this year it's time to figure out
financing and they face a major hurdle
there's literally one a few doors down
from us but with all the upgrades it's
also selling for you know half a million
less significantly lower than their 1.9
million dollar purchase price they worry
the bank will appraise the property at a
lower price leaving them to come up with
a difference between what they're able
to borrow and what they agreed to pay
matami a dream home has turned into what
they call a nightmare situation dozens
of buyers reeling from anime's Price
reductions a market that has cooled
significantly and higher interest rates
staged a protest last weekend mattamy
tells global news that it sells through
all Market cycles and Sells Homes at
prices that reflect the market at that
time it says if it can assist buyers
within the contractual boundaries of the
agreement of purchase and sale it may
explore that with individual buyers this
real estate analyst says it's bad timing
with painful Financial consequences he
see Market shocks expected and
unexpected happened before we saw this
exact scenario play out in 2017 in the
greater Toronto area when prices fell
rapidly he's hopeful households can find
a way to avoid a costly and complicated
default but he wants future buyers to
exercise caution before buying
pre-construction when Market Mania hits
when you see this massive exuberance and
crazy easy house prices and time those
are the periods when people should be
fearful and that's when you know
unfortunately people kind of get excited
and greedy and just want to buy a home
for Yasser and Rabia the waiting game is
a big source of stress in order to
bridge that Gap we have to come up with
400 to 500k more to be able to close our
house and we are just worried that if he
can't come up with that much money we
might end up losing our house and with
all the life savings with it and gaviola
Global News Toronto
[Music]
next climbing to new highs in order to
get over serious lows we'll bring you a
story that gives never giving up a whole
new meaning
[Music]
there are more problems on board the
International Space Station
NASA says another docked Russian
spacecraft had a depressurizing problem
springing a coolant leak Saturday it
doesn't pose a danger to anyone aboard
the station some cargo was affected
though it's filled with waste and it's
supposed to be thrown out in a few days
a similar coolant leak in December on a
different Russian spacecraft ended up
stranding two cosmonauts and one
astronaut on the ISS
a Canadian climber is reaching
remarkable Heights and shattering
records along the way Jill wheatley's
goal is to Summit 14 of the world's
tallest mountains and she's nearly
halfway there but what's more
significant is where she was forced to
climb out of and how she got to the top
as Jamie Dahl reports Wheatley is
achieving a vision after losing much of
her own
so thankful to be here 8 000 meters
beneath her feet she has now stood on
top of six of the world's tallest Peaks
the first Canadian woman to do so the
summit of K2 Pakistan
so thankful this is the second highest
point in the world and I was up there by
myself you know just a handful of years
earlier thinking that life wasn't worth
fighting for so I embrace impermanence
which with huge thanks
climbing these Giants is not even close
to the magnitude of the most difficult
Expedition Jill Wheatley has endured
in 2014 walking up these stairs was a
feat Wheatley a Competitive Cyclist and
Runner originally from Thunder Bay had
been teaching of his ed class in Germany
when she was hit by a baseball leaving
her with a traumatic brain injury and 70
vision loss she also developed an eating
disorder I really did not think that
life was worth living and I tried
everything I could to hurt myself and
and to try to end it so that's that's as
dark as it gets doctors and loved ones
refused to let her sit in that dark
crevasse and after 26 months in seven
different hospitals she eventually
climbed her way out with more Vigor than
ever hundreds of hands and hearts when
all is said and done who didn't give up
on me when I truly gave up on myself
those are the people those are the
reasons that I'm here today and I have
stood on top of six eight thousand meter
peaks in the last year she's heading
back to Nepal to begin the last half of
her project hoping to Summit the final
eight of the world's 14 tallest
mountains including of course Everest
she says she's not scared of death she's
already stared that in the face and she
refuses to see her injury as a
disability I call it Serendipity
I really believe you know you know
sometimes it takes time to learn or see
the lessons
but there's a reason things that things
happen and I didn't get to choose those
but I do have the opportunity to choose
how I respond and I'm choosing to
embrace the life I nearly lost and and
challenging myself in ways that um
I once definitely never thought possible
her motto losing sight to gain Vision
she's tackling the mountains of her mind
one step at a time hoping to inspire
others along the way
Jamie dog Global News
incredible that's global national for
this Sunday Super Bowl Sunday in fact
people in pubs across Canada are in for
a night of parties
we have a lot of people that are
regulars that we are asking us what time
are you showing the game what are you
going to be serving
now of course not everyone's an NFL fan
for them it's more about enjoying good
food with good friends
and you can count me as one of those
thank you for watching Donna's back
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other